now we are here doing the podcast
everybody does and they get canceled
you've been canceled twice by somebody
that we don't usually see people get
canceled by which is the Chinese
Communist party in Chinese social media
you get a lot of these over here you
call them social justice Warriors that
is their flavor they're very jingoistic
nationalist types people say oh can you
have you seen Uncle Roger work with this
guy then someone on Twitter now it's
West the Western World say oh have you
seen Uncle Roger apologizing and
kowtowing to the CCP I was like oh [__]
I read the statement back I was like oh
yeah okay it does sound like
what I know is I probably won't be able
to go to China or Hong Kong
in indefinite future everyone now online
has to be political you talk about food
yeah you now have to be political it's
insane I basically step on the landmine
thank you
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a terrific guest today is a
friend of ours from our old comedy
circuit days who is now absolutely
crushing it on YouTube he's got nearly 8
million subscribers Uncle Roger nigelong
is hello who you are welcome to
trigonometry thank you thank you it's
good to see you guys it's good to see
you man so many years on the comedy
circuit you know grinding away grinding
away now we are here doing the podcast
everybody does and they get canceled
son well I I didn't I didn't say I
didn't say that in your intro but you've
been canceled by China twice now yeah
we'll get on to that in a second uh but
before we do uh for people who don't
know you uh welcome to the podcast for
the canceled uh before before we talk
about that part of it what's your story
through life because we we know you well
but we actually probably don't know your
backstory uh where you from how did you
get here how did you find yourself
talking to us well I I'm I'm I was born
and raised in Malaysia and then in 20
2010 I left Malaysia to the US for my
University that's when I started doing
stand-up in 2015 I moved to the UK from
Chicago to London uh because I was
dating a woman who was from Germany
European woman at the uh we're not
together anymore but then we I moved
here with her continued doing the stand
up uh 2019 I went um full-time stand-up
I always had a day job throughout the
whole time two students to started doing
stand up in 2011 University had a day
job did stand up part-time four or five
nights a week 2019 September kind of had
like enough of a
like enough fees for me to go full time
and support myself I went full time six
months later covet hit lost all the work
I was like [__] can we curse on this yes
okay yeah I was like [__] okay I lost
all my work I have 10 months worth of
savings to to to to to live basically so
let's try to make something work online
uh at the time I had a podcast and I
also started doing YouTube so and that's
where my my character really took off uh
my character is called Uncle Roger
basically I played this middle-aged
Asian Uncle inspired by all these Asian
Boomers I see from my childhood you know
who talk a lot of [__] uh sassy attitude
but ultimately they're kind people so I
played this character online uh
critiquing
uh Western usually Western celebrity
chefs [__] up Asian food so the very
very first video uh that went viral was
the BBC food egg fried rice video drain
it drip what's she doing
what's she doing train the oh my God
you're killing me woman higher trainer I
just put on this orange Polo started
talking [__] and then when the video
when I posted a video I was at 7 000
subscribers that was June 2020 7000
subscribers and then the first week in
the video got ten thousand views oh [__]
that's pretty good yeah you know I was
like you know patting myself in the back
but later Reddit picked it up Nyan gag
picked it up Facebook Twitter it all
went viral in every platform Tick Tock
everywhere and so I just kept making the
videos went on a full World Tour doing
my stand-up as both my character and
then as myself which is a great way to
do it because you save money on an
opening act
pounds per gig extra of money
uh and then and then yeah just now we're
here so I just kept making the videos
kept doing stand up now I have um things
I'm developing with other production
companies and looking to move to LA for
work in a couple months so yeah it's
exciting stuff man yeah thank you I
remember we did the same gig above a pub
yes with you above a pub with you below
I used to do my gig below a pub and you
for people who wouldn't have seen your
stand-up you were always one of the
people that I think everybody on the
circuit like rated as really good thank
you you know thank you but you know when
you're good at stand up it's it's kind
of hard to get ahead if you're actually
like if you're too funny you know what I
mean yeah we don't have to get I have no
idea what he's talking about
I'm not saying I'm too funny but I think
sometimes sometimes especially in the
British comedy scene you have a very
theatrical culture yeah so when you
bring a show up to the fact the festival
here Edinburgh Fringe uh people want
like a theatrical structure to your show
so people who just focus on I just want
to be funny that doesn't work that well
but what helps us is because we do
online stuff funny actually goes viral
the theatrical artsy [__] harder to go
viral so I'm happy I found this little
path for myself and you did find this
little part for yourself and how has
your life changed Nigel from when we
knew you to how you are now
who has my life changed uh I use Adobe
Premiere Pro too much you know that that
just drives me crazy man uh honestly
like it's just such a relief you know
because you you're just hustling and
grinding and anonymity on the circuit
yeah I'm just every day coming from a
gig 11 P.M to midnight and just walking
home I have to go to my day job the next
day I wake up at seven and I'm like will
I ever be able to do this full time you
never know you know but now the fact
that you know I did a world tour it's
like 100 something shows over 50
something cities and then every I think
all the shows were sold out you see
people real life people coming to
support you you're like oh okay kind of
made it it's good it's a good feeling so
I think that's career-wise that's the
biggest change to have that that bit of
comfort and confidence that [__] will
work out you know it's good it's so
awesome man and the one you said relief
that is exactly the feeling that I have
as well and uh you would before we
started you were talking about how you
may may not do stand up going forward
which I can totally see because it's a
hard life too isn't it it's hard it's
really hard to do a write a good show
it's really difficult like the show I
did on my tour was the culmination of
like 10 years of my standup and then you
pick the best off and then see how much
I've workshopped those bids because I
have nothing else going on for me so I I
could just focus on the standard and
then the relief thing too I think maybe
I think that's an immigrant mentality
thing too you know oh it's going to go
away yeah yeah yeah yeah but you want to
make it right you want to get to where
you think you want to get to now I think
if I could do my whole life again I
would like to have Rich parents
that's the worst I had Rich parents for
a while you don't want that man really
no safety Isn't it nice the thing is you
get too comfortable and then you don't
want to do anything that's the problem
okay so you I want Rich parents who
still beat me once in a while yeah
that's the best rich Asian parents
you know you're gonna have a comfortable
life
yes I'm gonna I'm gonna actually I'm
gonna do that you know yeah yeah be rich
give my kids a good life mate you're
crushing so hard you could afford to pay
a random couple a load of money to be
your Rich parents yeah oh [__] that is a
good idea or someone when you have kids
to beat your kids
higher than like a nanny professional
kid beater yeah that'll be good that'll
be good do they hire do they have people
like that here in the UK probably what
we're discussing is now illegal but
anyway oops but what you're talking
about is really interesting because of
that relief thing because there's a lot
we know so many people on the comedy
circuit who were legitimately brilliant
and they're great and they Crush every
gig and their material is interesting
and people love them
but that's all they've got and you and
the fact that we made it out is
something that I will always be
eternally grateful for now do you ever
think about it think to yourself like
imagine if I didn't film that video that
day all right imagine if you didn't meet
each other and sit down and do this
podcast or oh you you started this
podcast with someone else I remember you
know it was not this podcast it's not
this part she likes to think it was but
it wasn't we know the guy do your
listeners know this story probably we've
had look we've had him on the show and
it's all good but it wasn't this podcast
yeah they were doing a different podcast
yeah I see I see but yes I I just think
back like imagine if I didn't have the
balls too because you put out something
like this
yes I I feel like I I have the fear when
I was putting it out oh what will my
comedy peers think of me exactly yeah
I'm playing this stupid character and
putting on a costume and then I'm people
are gonna say oh it's just a social
media comic and they all do think that
but it's like yeah it's it's okay I I
like million subscribers [__]
it's nice to go on nice holidays once in
a while and splurge on nice things for
myself no man it's great and it you know
one of the things that I always when we
were on the comedy circuit you know it's
a very [__] and kind of
hyper-competitive environment but when
you meet people who are successful or
when we used to they usually they were
the nicest people not always but usually
they were the nicest people and what I
realize now is I meet people who've done
what you've done and us to to a lesser
extent is like it's a lot easier to not
be in that desperation mindset of like
oh that person's got something and I
didn't it's a lot easier when you're
actually doing well yeah yeah
you know in the comedy industry too they
make it feel like a zero-sum game yeah
you know there's only eight spots on
mock the week eight spots on live at the
Apollo and four of them will go to
famous TV famous people yes and then
there's four uh one for each race
to me they're never going to put two
Asian people on Apollo at the same time
you know in case people get confused
right yeah yeah
and they create this this weird
zero-something but then the reality is
the the world on the Internet is
infinite almost it's seven billion
people eight billion people in the world
yeah you know and there's a lot of
Asians I [__] about Asian food mostly I
see how many Asians they are at every
city I go to Helsinki that's the Asian
guy half the crowd is Asian I'm like
where where how why would you move here
to this weird place from Vietnam you
know it's crazy yeah it is but and I
think that's
we're kind of conditioned when we're on
the comedy circuit to think like that
and what it happened is it created an
atmosphere where you just saw people
like you went into the open mic and
there was a kind of at the start this
almost kind of Brotherhood mentality you
know where guys doing comedy together
and it's you know we're all friends and
it's gonna be great and very quickly
things start to go really not very like
you know you see people there's a
there's there's a group who go nuts yep
you mean that they'll pull ahead of your
career no no I mean they go literally
nuts we all know the comedians who go
insane yeah doing it you know and they
quite literally lose their minds then
there's the other people you know and
there's the bitchiness yeah you're
looking back at it and you go that
wasn't a good place to exist it wasn't
it was not good good for mental health
it's not good for a wallet either no you
know it was good for your wallet but bad
for your mental health I'll still do it
but now nowadays I have to say when I
see a comedy show especially a UK one
and then I see a white guy like I see a
white guy laugh at the Apollo I'm like
[__] like
this must be good
yeah and that's a topic for another day
too but I I do appreciate this uh
they're making it more diverse but
sometimes I I do feel I'm put on just to
fulfill a quota and I know when I'm on a
lot of people viewing at home will say
oh he's on just for a quota but then
that kind of diminishes my my thing I
work really hard you know on the comedy
Circuit by that kind of diminishes it
but we don't I'm sure you guys have
covered them no no with not with uh
someone uh like you actually uh we
haven't I mean because coming from us it
sounds like you know white guys whining
yeah oh really whereas when you say it
it gives it legitimacy you tell us more
Nigel
um Asian guy whining yeah so like well
it is true that if I see a white girl in
the Apollo I'm like this is because this
guy is [__] good you know but then
when you see someone like like me on the
Apollo a lot of people will say think
that's a hurdle to cross first they're
going to think oh is he just a diversity
higher yeah then he sees they see that
in funny that oh okay he's actually good
so yeah and it's not just uh on on TV
shows when I do like random gigs and out
of the middle of nowhere I'm gonna get
on stage I I send some people saying
okay is this one of those diversity
things again so uh I win them over
because you know I've been doing this a
while but it would be nice if people if
we just it was more of an equal playing
field and funny where people didn't
bother about your skin color they were
just like you're funny you're not funny
yeah that's kind of the dream yeah but
that's that's what the internet is right
yeah you see something funny on Tick
Tock you share yeah so exactly that is
nice that we have such a thing like that
it is imagine if you started doing
stand-up in early 2000s where there was
no Tick Tock no YouTube yeah yeah that
would be rougher much much harder and
also as well there's the people at the
top who are Gatekeepers who come from a
certain structure of society so they
pick things they pick people or acts
that they like which she's fair enough
but you go well but you're just
excluding all these other people do you
know what I mean so if they want an
Asian guy they're going to get an Asian
Public School guy if they want a white
guy they're gonna get a white public
school girl yeah I feel like I feel like
you're really like talking [__] about
Phil Wagner
you're going to pick people you like
right because of course that's what you
you have to go off of and I I always
felt like my vibe wasn't my vibe wasn't
right for UK TV and and that's not like
a racism thing or anything it's like UK
TV like it's uh it's a little bantery
and softer I just go very hard insults
right yeah that kind of thing so uh the
internet works better for me for us yeah
absolutely and also as well it's because
we kind of like our comedians to be
victims here of going oh I'm so sad I'm
so fat I can't get girls I'm like what
are you talking about you're abusing
three backstage but anyway
Francis has been saving up for this
conversation
the The Comedians harassing women thing
what else do you need to get yeah I'm
gonna get it all up shoulders
exactly off the curb no
let's focus on you rather than on
francis's Trauma from the comedy circuit
days
um so one of the things is you like
you're very different to the type of
people that we normally have on the show
because very often we're talking about
quite serious things people got canceled
for saying the wrong thing blah blah
blah
you've been canceled twice by by
somebody that we don't usually see
people get canceled by which is the
Chinese Communist party yeah so I think
in total I've gotten canceled like four
times like four times yeah but China is
the most the the biggest ones the two
have to do with China the two biggest
ones the two other ones is one that
tweeted uh uh you know when Russia
invaded Ukraine that same day I was like
adding extra showing Kiev Guys Lincoln
bio so and then got some articles you
know not the best joke but it did
Inspire like a nice little bit that I do
on stage and yeah that got quite a bit
of quite a few views and then the other
small cancellation was I was touring
Singapore and talk [__] about their food
and Asians we take our food very
seriously but uh ended up well ended up
selling out the second show in Singapore
so that was that was good but yeah like
we are here to talk about like the two
the two big ones right so uh for a bit
of context because I grew up in Malaysia
I went to a mandarin speaking uh
secondary school so I'm Chinese
Malaysian my great-grandparents were
from China so I bring that up because in
Malaysia a lot of us we have we have
like Those Distant ties to China my
great care great grandparents were from
there so we have a little bit of an
affinity we still think of it as like oh
that's that's a cool place we consume
Chinese media and we speak the language
we have like friends from there we like
to visit there we we like we have a bit
more of affinity compared to the Western
World so that's a bit of a context from
how I grew up and where I come from so
the first Chinese cancellation uh that
was January 2021 so at this point I was
only maybe five months into Uncle Roger
and like just started to oh [__] I've
people i i people are paying attention
to me just started being known so I
didn't know what I was doing so I
collabed with this guy uh his name is
Mike Chen he runs a YouTube channel
called strictly dumpling and then you go
to his channel it's just food Vlog so I
thought oh yeah it's just a food vlogger
cool so we we reviewed this video
together we're over Zoom we are both
reviewing I think it was Epicurious or
uh some Food Network making a chef
making dumplings at it and doing a
horrific job about that you know so
we're just roasting the food whatever
edited the video posted it uh I I
remember I posted it and then I had to
go back to Malaysia to visit family
because Malaysia just started allowing
foreign residents in land in Malaysia
you have to quarantine for a week inside
a hotel room by yourself it is very
normal procedure at the time you get a
negative test quarantine the whole term
for a week and then I remember just
unpacking the hotel room sleeping waking
up and I got a message from my the
people who manage my Chinese social
media I just started uh way Boy and
Billy Billy at the time way boys Chinese
uh Chinese Twitter like platform and
Billy Billy is Chinese YouTube
so I just started those platforms paid a
bit of money up front for them to start
it and then I I got a message from them
saying my Chinese social media agent
saying hey Nigel your video you're
getting your accounts getting reported
because apparently that Mike Chan guy
from Strictly dumpling
is one uh very very
ntccp publicly on his social media and
two is also part of this organization
called falun gong are you familiar yeah
yeah okay you are by I guess so tell our
audience a little bit more tell our
words a little bit more about that yeah
it's
I have to be careful my words you're
doing against sued you know so yeah be
careful because we could get serious as
well so extra careful I hope you have
liability insurance yeah uh so it's an
organization
um a lot of people think it's a cult but
if you ask someone from falun gong
they'll just say they are an
organization a spiritual organization
that practices the the three Universal
truths of honesty forbearance and
compassion you know whatever that means
right but a lot of people online think
it's a cult right and it's a cult that's
very very let's think of it as Chinese
Scientology but apparently some [__]
happened uh when they were in China the
the founder of that of alun gong fled
China and nobody really knows what
happens just we I just know some [__]
has gone down and all this stuff is
impossible to research online especially
on Western internet
and uh like it's just impossible to find
you you'll find resources from falun
gong affiliate organizations say oh we
are just uh organized we just do tai chi
in the park every day you know why are
you Prosecuting us and then you see on
the China side I said no they did a lot
of crazy [__] back then so do your own
research are not gonna say anything that
would incriminate me so basically
if you're a seat in China if you're seen
working with someone from this
organization that's an automatic band
you'll be like Persona and grata you
can't even enter the country so that's
why my accounts were getting reported
because people think
in Chinese social media you get a lot of
these over here call them social justice
Warriors that is their flavor they're
very jingoistic nationalist types people
say oh can you have you seen Uncle Roger
work with this guy and then they would
just they have these National list Pages
they would have their fans report you
kind of doxing you you know so that's
how my accounts got uh um was about to
get suspended and I was like oh [__]
what do you do I I have no clue I was I
was new to this whole social media thing
right so I asked my Chinese social media
agents who were uh a lot of them all of
them were Chinese people based in China
so they said oh yeah well when something
like this happens usually we just issue
a statement and then then take down the
video that should go away and then and
then I was like oh okay I had no clue
right so I said just just handle it just
handle it so they wrote me a statement I
read it I was like oh yeah it feels like
you know copy and paste boilerplate a
statement yeah that's just fine just
post it but then I posted a statement
um
then then someone on Twitter now it's
West the Western World say oh have you
seen Uncle Roger apologizing and
kowtowing to the CCP I was like oh [__]
I read the statement back I was like oh
yeah okay it does sound like in
hindsight if if I if I were to do things
differently I would probably like be
more involved in in that process and be
like no let's not post this because it
does read like I am apologizing which
which I'm not I just you know like I
bring bring up the Malaysia Affinity to
China stuff because you know we I a lot
of Malaysians have Chinese social so
it's a normal thing to to have weibo and
Billy Billy you know it's not just a
money grabbing thing oh so to me it's
like okay maybe different social medias
have different rules I had no clue right
so I just if I could do it all over
again I would just be more
I'll look at a statement more closely
yeah see what it's a weird thing now in
the world searching Trump we'll get into
a second cancellation in a second but
it's like fourth man yeah but it's like
it's
I I instinctively think that generally
speaking if you don't feel you've done
anything wrong you shouldn't apologize
but on the other hand when you're new to
it you're just taking off you're trying
to manage the Fallout from something you
didn't even know about and didn't intend
well my Mandarin is also a bit Rusty now
and to me that letter didn't read like
an apology it just read oh uh I think if
you've translated it verbatim and feel
free to post the statement I I don't
need mine uh oh Uncle Roger uh I I
didn't know that Mike Chan had these
views towards the uh towards China so I
I hope you guys can give me a chance
because I'm new to this Chinese socials
I hope you guys will give Uncle Roger a
chance and uh uh uh and let give me a
chance and let me continue entertaining
you that that kind of thing so it didn't
read like an apology and also in China
people
the the Chinese audiences they're also
like like us normal people They Don't
Care they just want something funny to
watch you know so they also know oh yeah
it's just boilerplate copy and paste
it's Nigel's management team posting it
but in the west people just take it at
face value you know so it reads like an
apology so yeah
what does that feel like because you're
not somebody uh who's of early political
no no yeah
all of a sudden it hasn't and I when
when it happened I didn't even know why
I was canceled I was like I was
researching my cancellation in real time
and that's how I learned about all this
all this all this stuff and this it's
it's such such an incendiary thing and
uh what did it feel like so
we all remember I was stuck in a hotel
room by myself for seven days I was in
day two and my only access to the
outside world was the internet wow and
because uh it was such an incendiary
thing and there are Bots all over the
world they would just constantly send
you messages and you know their Bots
because it's different usernames but
they tweet the same exact message at you
um like they'll call me a a CCP
apologist uh genocide denier uh uh I'm
Pro human rights abuse and pro the
Tiananmen massacre all those things uh
Bootlegger CCP boot licker constantly
every two three seconds I had a new
comment like that on my Instagram Tick
Tock Facebook YouTube so just a constant
Onslaught I remember and read it as well
did you think you were gonna lose
everything yeah yeah at that moment yeah
I bet you did because again I was stuck
in the hotel room if I could go out and
see I was in Malaysia too so I'm
probably quite well known I am quite
well known back then there so if I had
the chance to leave the hotel room and
nobody gave a [__] he was like oh I love
your work Uncle Roger maybe at that
moment maybe some people would have just
been quietly ignoring me but I would
have noticed right I just think it
didn't know who I was uh but yeah if in
in that moment yeah I remember like like
first cancellation right first big big
and I just got successful for four
months
I I worked so hard 10 years of my life
working towards this I just started
being successful oh [__] is this all
gonna go away and people are tweeting at
me oh he's his career started with a
fried rice video ended with a dumpling
you know people are just brutal man yeah
yeah so yeah I did think I was gonna
lose it all
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch-up is on locals
are War shows still go out at 7 pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
it's interesting the reason I ask you is
we had a moment when we had only about
like a hundred thousand subscribers and
uh these a bunch of people came in and
they started spamming our our Channel
with a bunch of stuff down voting our
videos whatever
um and we definitely in that moment were
like whoa this like you know how you're
like you're just moving up and
everything's great and then suddenly
it's like whoa you know so that that's a
terrifying feeling yeah they don't
prepare you for this I remember I was
crying a lot too and uh well because
again you're stuck in the hotel room by
myself and my wow and my mom blessed her
she she follows my career very closely
every time there's a news article she
would send it to me oh look at you Nigel
this this newspaper in Malaysia is
reporting about you good job so the flip
side is every news article that says oh
Uncle Roger turns apparently is a pro
CCP apologist and he she would send me
the Articles
please I I know I know you you're
showing concern but this is not good for
me right now yeah yeah so that was rough
and the bot thing too when we get to the
the second cancellation team like
there's the Bots uh applied to both both
parties anything to do with China if you
approach China the Bots will come at you
if you're perceived as anti-china the
Bots will come at you as well and
another thing too that people don't say
the people don't warn you you have to
prepare yourself for getting hacked
once you are once you touch that topic
like like my we'll apply my special
later but my I'm hosting my special on
this website called moment.com and I
just got canceled on I think the news
article broke on BBC NBC on on Monday so
uh six days ago
My Moment uh account got hacked so a
moment is a platform where you can put
on uh something and then everybody can
buy a ticket it's a pay-per-view
platform you put on your content people
buy a ticket they can view it together
with you when it premieres so yesterday
night my My Moment uh account got hacked
it's all good now but then because I
went onto the page and they were just
like lewd photos and spammy links all
coming from my account and I was like
well I didn't do this so and this is
something that
uh I I I've worked with I work with a
lawyer who's been on um on on the side
of on he he just let's just say I don't
want to reveal too much but let's just
say he works on the thing that that
China doesn't like that he's working on
uh it's it's the it's the yeah so he he
he told me he just warned me just okay I
have been through this and he's also
lived in China so he knows like what
it's like he said yeah be prepared set
up two-factor authentication and
everything uh things are gonna get
hacked and yeah I do have my other
platforms I get uh text messages saying
oh did you sign try to sign into your
Instagram account here's a confirmation
code that kind of thing so Instagram
moment.com My Moment account definitely
got hacked and then the other socials
hopefully they are still okay I haven't
I it's okay so far wow man yeah you know
with our journey we are overtly
political with what we do we talk about
politics we comment on politics we make
jokes about politics or videos but
everyone now online has to be political
you talk about food yeah you now have to
be political it's insane it's I
basically step on the landmine you know
the the fact that to me that video was
not political right but the fact that
and I didn't even post it on Chinese
socials but somebody from Chinese social
screenshotted me on YouTube working with
this Mike Chen guy and then posted on
weibo and Billy Billy and I said look at
this Uncle just working with a known
cultist and then uh that made it
political so at that point it was loose
loose either way if I kept the video up
I would have nuked my Chinese socials if
I took the video down the question would
would have hated me you know so who did
you pick well at that time I was like oh
I just thought of the Chinese I didn't
know it was going to be such a big deal
it was my naivete and I owned that
mistake now definitely so yeah I picked
taking a video down because I was like
oh my Chinese fans seemed cool they like
they're like me let's just keep it going
yeah uh and that became very political
and then when I took the video down the
Western world started hating on me uh
Mike Mike Chen he was I this pissed me
off a little bit you know because sure I
did have to unfollow him on my Chinese
social media uh agent's orders and I
think he he he should know what is going
on but then he just went on all this
because he's part of the falungo and
this is a known fact he promoted on his
channel that he's part of this
so as most people they will know Shen
Yun that that show the Chinese uh tube
adverts and see a lot of two adverts on
the show so that that's just Affiliated
so right right when the Western world
started hating me my chance started
doing his whole rounds of podcasts
because the falungo owned a lot of
YouTube channels you know the The Epic
Times is that's how I know about it
because we've I've done a couple of
shows on their platform and we know
someone there who's actually not Chinese
yeah yeah I think it's part part of it
yeah it's not is that is the Western
Falcon's Western arm and then they also
have the new Tang Dynasty which is a
YouTube channel uh a few other channel I
think China uncensored on YouTube is
also part of the organization and a lot
of people say that's not me a lot of
people are saying that my Chen is pretty
high up in the Falcon organization so he
has friends in all these channels and he
was doing just a podcast around like you
know doing the Rogan circuit yeah was he
slagging you off was he was that what
happened yeah yeah this is three under
the bus a little bit Yeah it threw me
under the bus so that was why I was a
little bit oh come on dude I'm new to
this world I'm operating off the back
foot here I don't know I don't even know
why I got canceled I'm researching
everything and they threw me under the
bus so now people say uh we will get to
the second cancellation but people ask
now that China hates you but are you
gonna put on that old dumping video out
so I was like nah because it just
doesn't feel great being a pawn in this
in this war between the the China
Chinese China China's the ccp's
propaganda and then the salunkong's
propaganda so yeah it's just left a
shitty taste in my mouth is this whole
thing yeah of course but what was great
about that was really heartening to see
is that you transcended that you moved
on you are crushing it you know this the
socials were exploding you were doing
brilliantly thank you thank you and you
still are and you still are and then uh
and then last week I went on Twitter I
went oh Nigel's Nigel's videos popped up
on my feed that's unusual what's going
on with and then something else happened
yep yep so fast forward two years later
I have to say your first cancellation is
it's like losing a virginity yeah it is
you know it's memorable but for all the
wrong reasons
I wish it lasted I didn't know what you
were doing you know all that but it
lasts a lot longer you know a
cancellation now I think the last time
around like two weeks where you kept
getting messages a pro tip for it for
you guys you probably run into this soon
uh when you get JK Rowling on this
podcast yeah set up uh comment filters
like keyword filters on your for your
comments on all your socials because
you'll get people Bots copy and pasting
the same thing so that's how you filter
them out you know you guys should get
Joanne on man yeah Joanne Rowling yeah
she should come on who who else who else
will interview her this is the podcast
to be it's JK Rowling we know you're
listening Uncle Roger's spoken
but anyway so fast forward two years
later you recover from the initial
cancellation right because the thing
that people don't tell you about getting
canceled at least in that way is if you
just let it go and let it pass
it's actually fine two weeks later yes
but there's a caveat though I think to
us it is like that but to someone who
has who's regular employment yeah maybe
a little trickier for them so we do have
a little bit of a privilege there but
yes you just have to keep trucking on
keep hustling I did lose a few sponsors
I did lose quite a bit of money with
throughout the whole thing uh but
eventually the sponsors come back and uh
yeah that's a bit of money it's fine
just just put put away safe when you're
entertaining you should put away some
stuff because you know shit's gonna
happen you know yeah so fast forward two
years later
um I I finished my tour so I'm about to
release uh my special Dropping Drop in
June 4th click Link in description
um I'm about to release my special so to
release it because it's a pay-per-view
you want to drum up some sales right so
you want to put out some small Clips as
a marketing
so one of the clips I chose you know you
when you put out a clip a clip that
works well for marketing is a clip that
will go viral because the more people
see it the more people buy it obviously
right so I was like okay what what
clip's gonna go viral so because I've
been through the cancellation I know
that this China stuff my instinct tells
me this this bit will will ruffle some
feathers so feel free to put that bit in
where are you from are you from Boston
uh originally from Guangzhou China China
okay China good country good country
we have to say that now correct
oh the phone listening oh the phone
listening
his nephew got Huawei phone they are
you use expense VPN
[Applause]
don't let your government hear that
please
oh our phone tap into it Long Live
presidency Long Live presidency
Uncle Roger social credit score going up
from China okay anyone anyone any is a
nephew from Taiwan
[Applause]
not a real country not a real
not a real country
I hope one day you rejoined the
motherland One China
foreign
I basically
um
kind of kind of marked both sides you
know I think that's a good comic you
need to play both sides and get both
sides pissed off at you otherwise it
feels you feel more like a politician if
you're just a very Pro or leaning
against one side right so in that bit I
may I think I I pulled off making fun of
both uh China and and Taiwan at the same
time and again these are all jokes you
know I come to my show there's maybe
like just just that joke kind of touches
on a political nerve somewhat lightly
but the things I say is like oh Huawei
for they're all listening that's kind of
things we all say right yeah right yeah
oh China is all they're all listening oh
anyone from Taiwan or not a real country
not a real country that's kind of jokes
that's like the standard in a comedy
club you find out where someone's from
you make fun of their country yeah move
on to the next person that's what you do
it's not even that big a deal it's just
no maybe I I know more about this
because of my cancellation so I I could
like I was quick and off the coffin and
a little bit of a spoiler here I've done
the joke many times you know it looks
like this you know improvise oh you're
from China no a lot of my shows I have
people from China coming to my shows and
um I have to say I still like close to
100 000 tickets for the tour that bit
worked everywhere you know uh I I did
have to cancel Taiwan but that wasn't
because of the bit that was because the
covet restrictions were still there uh
so it worked everywhere I know it's a
good bit I know it's uh it's funny and I
know it also will ruffle some feathers
it's a little bit slightly controversial
and it's just fun
so I know that was gonna do well I
didn't know I was gonna do this well
yeah appearing on BBC and everything so
I posted that and then um uh again the
same thing happened somebody I didn't
post it on Chinese socials because yeah
on Chinese socials you can't really
mention the president by name that is
just a No-No and
why go through the trouble I have a
feeling they're gonna be pissed off at
this and I was right but I didn't post
it on any Chinese socials somebody again
some nationalists way more person
screenshotted that and then posted it on
their accounts and then my account got
reported and suspended this time so now
even though you didn't post it I didn't
post it so they haven't banned you for
breaking the rules of weibo they've
banned you for having the what they
think is the wrong opinion even though
it's just a joke essentially initially I
got banned because of the reports from
other people but my Chinese social media
team my current one has recently
informed me that that ban also is not
just a social media platform but it also
came from higher up but whatever that
means I don't know what that means what
I know is I probably won't be able to go
to China or Hong Kong in the uh in
indefinite future which is you know it's
the price I have to pay I can still go
to Taiwan hopefully before China like
nukes them I should go before I can see
why you got canceled
so so you you have that video we'll
we'll include it in this if yeah it's
okay uh and then your Chinese social
media accounts get nuked anything else
uh I'm I think all four of them got nuke
right yeah I'm like four four Chinese
socialists now so and then
I I I've learned from last time I know I
know if I make any sort of statement
trying to like say oh on Chinese social
just saying that oh it's just a joke
guys and by the way the Chinese fans on
my socials and they all know it's just a
joke it's like they all they all enjoy
it it's just this very tiny it's kind of
like the Western World too right the
social justice jingoistic Warriors
they're like oh I can't believe he
humiliated China this there's a term in
in Mandarin currently it's a very trendy
term called ruhua and it translates to
humiliate China and then uh there's a
joke in the Taiwanese like and the
anti-china country circles that go like
uh uh humiliating China is the thing
everybody goes through because they are
so sensitive that kind of thing so there
are three things in in life that you
will do you were born you humiliate
China and you die
so and and I just learned about all of
this and it is true there's a very vocal
very sensitive people who who will
report everything uh and coincidentally
when I was canceled the day before there
was a Chinese comedian his name is Lee
House
he made a joke I listened to that joke
he just said oh I saw some a few dogs
and they were like she was really really
energetic and I really want him to
protect my house because those dogs
reminded me of and he said the Chinese
military catchphrase uh I forgot to
catch him but he basically used that
catchphrase in that bit and the Bitcoin
and Applause break I listened to that
actual bit so everybody in the comedy
club found it funny but apparently
somebody recorded illegal footage of
just audio posted it he he might face
three months in jail he he his
management company is fine 1.5 million
uh pounds wow yeah so it is fortunate
that you know I'm not my nationality is
not Chinese you know my ethnicity yes
you know Chinese but that that that's
always tricky Isn't it nice to be white
sometimes you know what I mean
I have like some like I I I we have ties
to China my family has distant types of
China so I was like oh yeah let's start
this Chinese social media so now look
look at look where I ended up you know
just all this headache and sometimes I
also feel that not having Chinese
socials is also
long term from it's also more freeing
for your comedy man because there's so
many things that you don't even know
will be consumed as offensive in China
for for example I use I reviewed this
video I think it was a Jamie Oliver
video making um he was making some sort
of fried fish and he wrapped the fish in
Banana Leaf right so I was like oh the
Banana Leaf doesn't look fresh but it's
okay because he probably imported that
Banana Leaf all the way from Malaysia to
the UK so in that in that I had an
animation of a banana leaf on a world
map just flying from my editor that made
this animation from flying from Malaysia
all the way to the UK but that world map
that he downloaded had the word Taiwan
on it
and then my Chinese social media person
is like uh you can't post this video you
have to take this Z now otherwise you
you you know what's gonna happen and I
said okay oh well he spent so much time
making his animation can we just keep
that scene in but keep the scene in for
the YouTube version I mean do it
something differently for the for the
Chinese socials and she was like no you
you can because again they're gonna
screenshot that and post it on weibo and
Billy Billy so this kind of thing is
like I want to I like my Chinese fans
you know and and they like me too but
just there's just so much [__] that you
don't even think it's offensive there
will be misconstrued as offensive that
will get me Newton anyway so oh well no
were you ever under pressure as well
from from your agents not to put that
clip out or when you put that clip out
to apologize because they're going hang
on a second here you're going to lose
this in time Market it's huge Uncle
Roger could be absolutely massive over
there just played the game
Etc
um I have credit to my agent that he he
was very uh supportive he just he he
leaves all the creative decisions to me
you know so uh he he didn't come and say
oh no don't put that think of the
Chinese market my Chinese social media
team do do think that obviously right
that's their job if if they post
something that will knowingly get me
nuked on China they'll get fired so yeah
I know where they're coming from but my
agent has been just very all about it
you know uh he he knows what I'm doing
and also they you say I do I I have lost
all my Chinese socials and yeah sure you
lose a little bit of money but you also
win new fans right you also win fans who
are like oh [__] this Uncle Roger guy
has balls [__] respect you know so yeah
it's it's not a business calculation I
don't exactly know where am I ahead or
am I would have made more money if I
apologize but it's like
as a comic it just feels right to make
fun of every side you know what I mean
you know DNA we still have that I want
to talk [__] about everybody yeah so if
if
and if I put out a clip like that on my
own terms I knew what was going to
happen and I knew that clip was funny I
can stand behind it I wouldn't apologize
that's just something I I told myself
it's a better way to live man yeah it's
a better way to live yeah I probably
won't be cast in any Disney film or any
Marvel film but
it's not I'm getting casted in there
anyways
it's fine well they're not trending a24
is a trendy now anyway and then cast
cast mean that you know
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship you
know it does take Integrity to know that
although we make a joke about it there
is a very real chance or there was a
possibility that you could have at least
had an audition for something like that
that path could have been open to you
but by doing this you know that you've
closed that gate
well Fran's just rubbing it in so so be
it right you know you you sometimes you
have to say yeah my life is pretty
comfortable I make enough money that's
okay if I don't have a yacht for the
rest of my life that's fine and more
than that I think you're right though
Nigel in the I think actually what
you'll probably find is long term this
benefits your career rather than
hindering it uh yeah maybe I think it
will I I definitely think it will
because as a comic too like you get on
stage someone says he's from China come
on like what are you gonna say oh China
okay moving on come on this is the new
the Chinese fire balloon
comic come on like you you'll be
disingenuous if you don't mention
something right yeah and what do you
what are your opinions now because now
that because before you went into this
you must have had one opinion no no
let's not call it China the CCP but
having dealt with them having scrapes
with them what do you use your opinion
now of it
um I'm not the most political guy yep
but I do think yeah they are a little
they're a little sensitive to jokes and
they're cracking down on Comedy like
I don't know like this recently they've
cracked down on Comedy even more and
they're cracked down on like Western
uh uh entertainment like bands on there
even more because I was in this New York
Times article so I was reading I was
like oh [__] it's not just happening to
me and that other Chinese comedian like
a lot of like uh Western bands or
Japanese bands groups they certainly had
to cancel appearances for no good reason
so
I don't know I
I don't I never really thought about
them the CCP that much now I just feel
like my opinion is like uh is it would
be really hard to
to not offend anybody on their platforms
and the thing is on Western platforms if
you offend someone it's still fine they
still let your platforms keep going
right that's how you know you guys and
Rogan got so big because
um
they just let Let It Be it's more it's
there's more leeway here I'm not saying
speech is completely free on on Western
media it's probably not but it's a lot
definitely a lot a lot Freer than in
China well this is why I always say that
like cultures or countries or regimes or
whatever where comedy censored like the
moment you start to see comedians being
censored you're like this is this is
this place is going in the wrong
direction you know what I mean and that
seems to be like what you're saying
there as well
um it's interesting yeah I mean I
haven't I haven't thought about it like
that but yeah yeah don't put words my
mouth man but no I wasn't saying about
China specifically I actually think in
the west as well like the reason I
sometimes get annoyed by people being
censored is that to me that's a move
towards that direction like growing up
in the Soviet Union I saw this and so
I'm kind of like let's not go let's not
move in that direction do you know what
I mean yeah but you also can't just post
a video of you say in the end where it's
like a thousand times right I don't know
have you tried
I'm not trying look I'm not trying to
put any words in your mouth at all I'm
genuinely curious I was just saying the
reason that I talk about uh restrictions
on jokes and speech in general in the
west is that I don't like that the West
seems to me at least to be moving
towards I'm not saying anything like
that you see what I mean yeah yeah I
don't know if that makes sense too
because you don't have to agree moving
towards that maybe it is I just I have
to pay attention things much but I do I
do listen to to the trigonometry and uh
yeah yeah
it has been an opinion that's echoed a
lot on social media too yeah so but you
don't agree with it
I haven't thought about it enough to to
agree yeah I think I think uh
maybe because I haven't been personally
affected that much until but when I'm
affected it's from the Chinese side
right yeah but you also did it actually
it's a different point uh not about
censorship at all but I I my sense isn't
actually that it's just happening in the
west or it's just social justice people
like there's people who are like the
opposite of social justice people they
get just as triggered by someone saying
something they don't like either so I
just think it's social media in general
makes people feel like everyone should
give a [__] about their opinion do you
know do you see what I'm saying I I yeah
and I know what you mean and also the
the echo chamber doesn't help because
any opinion you express there'll be tons
of people agreeing with you you know
yeah even though it's a very extreme
view of things
but I like social media Tick Tock is fun
though you know yeah you know it's good
hey look and let's be fair there's
plenty to criticize Nigel with social
media and we can talk about it to the
you know the proverbial cows come home
yeah but this wouldn't have happened
without social media Uncle Roger
wouldn't have happened without social
media we all in this room have a lot to
be grateful to social media for Andrew
Kate would have happened
that guy is so entertaining right oh you
should have him on have you has he been
on no he hasn't been okay
guys the most entertaining guy man yeah
why'd you like him he's he's ridiculous
don't they advice from him I'm saying
don't don't listen to him at all but
he's just like uh you know when you text
your girl never text her in the morning
text her 11 p.m or 1am and then she's
like baby why aren't you a stupid and
say money doesn't sleep baby and then
don't reply to her [__] that's G
that's so funny he's like a cartoon
version of how to pick up women
and then the the thing with Greta
tanberg you know he got arrested because
he was like mocking her it's just you
can't write this [__] he's like a sitcom
character it is like a sitcom character
I sometimes think about this uh my
girlfriend's made this point she goes
look social media is just the new soap
opera that's all it is there's the
characters people fall out have you
heard what he said about her and she
said about him and all this and this is
really important and you go out in the
big wide world and no one cares yeah
because it's a complete soap opera
exactly exactly you get the people on
Reddit who care I was just shopping
around for a Japanese knife right it has
to do with the story trust me and then I
go there and then he brings out this
beautiful knife I said oh this this one
is 1500 pound wow uh Japanese Cleaver
and then he's like yeah you know you
should buy this manager but he knows who
I am he knows I do like food stuff he's
a buddy because everybody on Reddit
loves this knife this this Japanese
knife it doesn't make knives anymore he
retired so this is the one of the last
three knives in the world in circulation
everybody on Reddit will love you I'm
like I just want to chop some spring
onions mate I don't care Reddit will
love my my new [__] knife 1500 pounds
for a knife I can do that you you won't
even use it if you're too too careful
too scared yeah that is true so what is
the future hold now for you Nigel that's
a future Hole uh well I hope the launch
of my special will go well we'll do a
full plug at the end and I I think you
know I've plugged about four times
already like what what
uh I I I'm releasing that and um you're
releasing that in fact as people are
watching this it's already out yeah it's
already out today and it will be uh
online available for purchase and
viewing for two more weeks after June 18
it will be gone uh by the way the
premiere date is June 4th and today yeah
today which is annoyingly I just picked
that premiere date because my videos I
put out my videos on Sundays yeah right
and then I wanted to release sit like
soonish before summer before summer so I
said oh June 4th apparently June 4 1989
is the day of the Tiananmen massacre so
I'm like I can't do anything
you guys are reading too much into this
and then the people who are ntccp
they're like cheering for me yeah Uncle
Roger [__] so smart bro look at this
he's putting on June 4th and then he
knows what he's doing no no it was just
a coincidence and then in my video I had
a response video to the cancellation me
and character chopping spring onions are
going like high yeah I got canceled yeah
but you know I'm just talking [__] go
buy the special or just doing some
marketing for it and then apparently
chopping spring onion also has a hidden
metaphorical meaning in China of like
the government ripping off the the
people something like that oh I think
chopping chives is the is the is the is
the term and then people are like yeah
go Uncle Roger you know he's he's an
artist he has so many hidden meanings in
his videos
man I think you're gonna go and click on
the photo of his special it's just you
doing this behind the American flag
just just come out with it you've put
all the dates you've been hinting with
the chives The Chopping the everything
if you guys buy the special I'll be a
practitioner start downloading a
meditation video tai chi in the park yes
I'm gonna be one of those protesters say
you'll see them in Chinatown and say oh
China's harvesting our organs that's the
falun gong so I'll join one of your
marches falun gong if you buy the
special moment.com
I feel the same as ever just a pure
businessman he's a zero [__] given I
like that he's just all I remember you
when you're at the end of a gig and
we're all there being these quick little
comedians going I hope someone likes me
and then neither was at the front
watching the people going back handing
out business cards yes I did that for a
little bit I was so I wish QR codes were
a thing back then yeah you know but they
weren't that was pre-covered no but you
were always very driven I remember we
started I think we started trigonometry
what we did we started trigonometry
before you started on Uncle Roger yeah
depression thought and you were still
looking for the thing that you were
gonna do and you were always asking
about you know how do you do this how do
you do that and I just I do think that
work ethic is a big part of the reason
you're here honestly oh thank you very
much yeah I'm serious man like I always
really noticed that about you first of
all you were good and secondly you were
really driven ah thanks because if I run
out of money I would be sent home to
Malaysia you know I don't have a backup
plan you know not saying Malaysia is bad
but I would like to you know continue
doing what I love doing in this country
uh but the future holds I'm moving to La
for work I'm gonna start splitting time
there and here and I I feel Americans
work too hard you know I talked to as a
YouTuber I work with recently and his
name in Google he's a state guy uh love
his stuff he worked together on a few
videos and he was like oh the last
holiday he's on holiday right now in
Japan I see his stories but he told me
yeah I'm going to Japan and the last
holiday I took was seven years ago I had
four days off
and I was in uh Americans work too hard
if there's a country that it's between
like American work ethic and British
work I think I think I'm there yeah yeah
I think I'll be too lazy for Asia
but too hard working for Britain yeah
yeah I mean that's not saying a lot
though is it
that is weird when you come back from
America and you just look around you go
nothing works here in comparison and you
can kind of see why yeah there's no one
really good I think it works here and
they're proud that it doesn't work
that's what I like about Britain really
yeah don't give a [__] man they like
they like tradition they like the old
things you know there's period houses
America in America you just bulldoze it
down yeah something yeah I live in a
nice period house and it's it's actually
a rare to it's impossible to live in one
like that in Asia because every 30 years
40 years they bulldoze everything down
especially in Japan their houses
actually go down in value because they
know after a certain number of years
they'll rip it all down and start afresh
which is pros and cons right but here
you have these Charming little things
because people are too lazy to bulldoze
it down and rebuild it so that's how you
get the period houses
so there we go well Nigel listen it's
great to see you crushing it thank you
it's great to see you pissing off all
the right people and I don't even know
who that is no everybody's mad everybody
anyone who wants to get pissed off on
social media is the right person to piss
off at this point it's just all crazy uh
but it's great to see you doing well uh
I'm sure the special is going to crush
uh remind people where they can go and
get that oh sixth time for the fifth or
sixth time uh you can buy it today right
now at moment.com Mr Nigel UNG link will
be in description this is the show that
I've been touring with Uncle Roger uh
for the last year and a half uh you'll
both see Uncle Roger does like 20
minutes then I do about an hour and uh
it's a good show uh I'm very very proud
of it please go buy it all right and
Nigel we're gonna go uh to questions
from our supporters in a second that
only they will get to see the answers to
on locals but before we do that we
always end with the same question which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
oh boy see I was dreading this question
um it's a free hit man yeah unplug the
special game
no Jesus I think
um
I think we should all just go outside
more and be near nature and and put down
the phone
and uh oh God what am I saying
I was gonna say you live in central
London mate what are you talking about
yeah just just that's why you got to
start driving because it's the only time
you don't look at your phone you know I
think everybody has to just just just
just just just just just go touch some
leaves and stop being mad at me you know
that's what we're not talking about
that's the one thing people don't even
talk about me more but in a nice way
let's leave some nice comments do you
reckon he's gonna plug it again before
we wrap it yeah I think so we we
about to hit the hour mark
more time all right go and check your
special out otherwise oh he's never
going to show up about it we'll see you
on locals guys
that I can get behind but it's rare to
find
something else
absolutely [__] disgrace
foreign
[Music]